one other Herschel Walker story I have a
clip of Marjorie Taylor green radical
republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green who represents the state of
Georgia after all in the House of
Representatives
she even is admitting
asking people to vote for Herschel
Walker
that's asking a lot take a listen to
this I really need Georgia to get out
and vote for
vote for please do it
um I know I know what we're asking a lot
of you but we need you to get out there
and vote there is a lot more to what it
looks like than just a Republican and a
Democrat this is the future of our
country this is the future for our
children and it it's also the way your
money is spent in Washington so
um I'm asking you to get out and vote
for my friend Herschel Walker and of
course fellow UGA Bulldog we're always
so proud of him of course
football team in the years that he
played there and um it would just be
wonderful it'd be great to have a dog up
there in the Senate so hot dog yeah
she's all but saying to Republicans
listen
you've got to hold your nose and vote
for Walker to block Raphael Warnock from
being a member of the Senate someone
wrote to me and they said David do you
think Marjorie Taylor green means that
it's a lot to ask to vote for Walker
because Walker is a bad candidate or
because Walker is black and I thought
that's a very low blow we have no actual
evidence that that's what Marjorie
Taylor green meant let's not even go
there but it is a theme that even some
of the wackiest Republicans and without
a doubt Marjorie Taylor green qualifies
as one of those
some of the wackiest Republicans seem to
recognize this entire Herschel Walker
thing it's not a particularly good idea
and so Step One is we've got to get
through tomorrow hopefully Raphael
Warnock is uh voted uh wins and stays in
the Senate and um Herschel Walker is
gone and we never hear from him again in
a political space he can go back to
doing whatever else he wants to do the
next step is have Republicans
learned in a sense that it wasn't a
great idea to run these wacky candidates
and that Trump's endorsement alone
doesn't seem to be enough to get some of
them past the Finish Line we saw it with
J.R Majewski we saw it with John Gibbs
we saw it with Doug mastriano we saw it
with Mehmet Oz we're hopefully going to
see it with Herschel Walker will they
learn
and if so is that actually worse for
Democrats in the sense that they might
nominate people more likely to win
that's a story for later in the next 24
hours vote vote vote we're going to take
a quick break make sure you're
subscribed on YouTube at youtube.com the
davidpackman show just a reminder if I
sound weird I have coven I had a brutal
30 hours of fever over the weekend
during which I uh watch world cop and
watched um
oh I watched the new Argentinian film
1985 about the prosecution of uh those
at the head of the military dictatorship
in the in Argentina in the late 70s very
very good film and then Like a Phoenix
rising over the horizon my fever cleared
and now I have a cold but I am here and
that is what matters okay quick break
back right after this